now that interim report that we of
course heard yesterday found that Boris
Johnson may have misled Parliament
several times it doesn't look good for
him does it
well I think we need to remember whose
evidence that we're relying on here this
privileges committee is relying on
evidence now as has been proven by a
report from the chief of staff of the
leader of the opposition I mean this
this is just ludicrous I mean if it
wasn't so serious it would be laughable
relying on evidence from a report
compiled by the leader of the
opposition's chief of staff I mean I
just think this makes it makes a whole
process look utterly ludicrous
well see gray isn't yet uh the chief of
staff and in fact the committee did did
speak out and defended themselves
yesterday saying that you know they uh
the findings were not based on Sue
Gray's report and in fact that it
included a lot more evidence and many
more photos so you know you can't you
can't say that this is down to sue
Gray's report and in fact the committee
also complained that it was difficult to
get evidence from Boris Johnson or
suggest he was obstructive well hang on
a minute that's exactly what I'm telling
you and it's actually based upon their
own words themselves they say they rely
on Sue Gray's um a report in in the
report that they uh published so so
that's absolutely clear at the end of
the day we're trying this is a um a
report which one of the biggest seismic
political events of the past 12 months
we had an MP uh a prime minister that
was elected on a majority of 80 and we
ended up getting rid of him on the basis
of uh a few photos of a birthday party
which looks
to be honest it's not a very exciting
birthday party it makes us look utterly
ludicrous to the rest of the world and
quite frankly now it's I think it goes
against more natural Justice when we
realize that it's based on a report
produced by the legal positions Chief of
Staff I think the whole thing's
ridiculous well you can say that but the
Privileges committee who produced this
interim report the majority of the MPS
on that committee were conservative and
the report includes one witness saying
that the then prime minister of course
Boris Johnson told a pact gathering at
number 10 in November 2020 that this is
probably the most unsocially distanced
gathering in the UK right now now you
you can't dispute what a what an
eyewitness has said can you well of
course you kind of you see the picture
of it a packed Gathering I mean if this
was supposed to be a party it's probably
one of the worst parties I've ever seen
in my entire life I mean the whole thing
makes is a mockery of natural Justice
and makes us a laughing stock around the
world you know I'm in Bulgaria right now
and I'm I remember going to an event in
with some school children
they
they yeah that we got rid of him because
of a few soggy sandwiches from
Sainsbury's is got a complete joke and
again it's um evidence that this is
based upon a report from the chief of uh
staff to the leader of the opposition it
just looks like a complete stitch up I
mean I just don't understand why anyone
could think any differently you may say
that Boris Johnson you know is very
popular in Bulgaria I've spent a lot of
time in Ukraine they like him there too
but it doesn't mean that he's popular
domestically just because he's popular
internationally and certainly when you
say that you know you know just because
a few soggy sandwiches were dragged into
Downing Street that that doesn't feel
fair either when there are photographs
of Boris Johnson surrounded by lots of
bottles of alcohol just why is he
continuing to fight this is he is he
still trying to make a political
comeback to be prime minister do you
think
I think he's continuing to fight this
because it's a perversion of natural
Justice
um the the idea I just keep saying to
you that this is based based on evidence
from a report compiled by the uh Chief
of Staff division of the opposition it's
just completely ludicrous I think anyone
who looks at this objectively would
reach the same conclusion and you say
surrounded by bottles and everything
else if you look at these pictures and
you're trying to make out that this is
evidence of parties going on a Downing
Street he looks like the worst part
you've ever been to in my entire life
it's not a party anyone who looks at the
pictures Can can see for themselves the
whole thing is ridiculous
of course Boris Johnson could
potentially be sanctioned uh following
this uh Committee hearing
um do you think he could be suspended
from Parliament
well I think if that happened then we we
no longer live in a serious country I
mean we we've got
um you know
you can sit there and you can turn
around and say well you know this
happened X happened it's evidence of of
parties and down Institute I think
anyone who empirically or independently
looked at this evidence would um would
realize that that's absolutely
ridiculous Boris Johnson was a Prime
Minister elected by um the overwhelming
majority of the country 80 seat majority
and um the way his reputation has been
besmerged the way uh this has happened I
think is evidence of not a serious
country and the fact that is based upon
as I say evidence compiled by the leader
of the opposition's chief of staff I
think goes against all natural Justice
well she's not the chief of staff yet
and it's not just a job it's not just
Sue great it's not just Sue gray who
investigated is it the Metropolitan
Police also did and they issued 126
fines so what do you say to that
well they issued 126 fines that Boris
Johnson didn't get 126 fines to find
that Boris Johnson
we've got for the Soggy sandwiches and
the the slice of birthday cake that I
think if anyone as I say looked at uh
utterly uh objectively would think was
ridiculous uh and you know you I think
the inconsistency in the police's
approach especially when you look at
Arma and swigging beers in a curry in
Durham I think um well people can reach
their own conclusions can't they
what does the party need to do to move
on
well we have moved on we've got a new
prime minister and uh we're getting on
with the job what I'm here to talk to
talk to you about is um is Boris Johnson
and as I say I think um if we're going
to keep continuing continually going
down this line if we're going to
continually uh look to try and affect
the reputation of a man who was elected
on a um on a major mandate I I just
don't think we're a serious country
a lot of people are today saying that
his political future is in Peril he only
has a very slim majority in his West
London seat
how do you think the future looks for
Boris Johnson today
well Boris Johnson will make his own
decision about whether he wants to
continue to fight he he said he's going
to continue to fight we can sit there
and say we can look at his majority we
can look at my majority we can say well
that looks a pretty pretty um perilous
isn't it but look the people will decide
and I think uh that that's what's
important but Boris Johnson is a
colleague he's a member of the my
parliamentary party I hope that he
continues to do so and uh he's uh and
again he's I think his reputation it
absolutely needs to uh be defended he
was elected on a significant uh majority
and I'm sure he'll continue to make a
considerable impact on British political